thank you so our goal today is to
continue talking about the program is a
metagenomics onyx logic metagenomics
program and we'll talk about it
starting from kind of at the beginning
so last time we did an overview of the
program we talked about what types of
applications of metagenomics we will be
looking at and we talked a little bit
about the structure of the whole program
today what we'll do is we'll start
talking about how we can study microbial
communities using sequencing so we'll
give a few more minutes for people that
are joining to join the program and in
the meantime what I wanted to go over
are some of the technical details of the
program and how everybody can register
on the platform and get access to the
courses and to the platform that we'll
be using throughout the course to
analyze the data and learn about some of
these examples so let's let me just show
you a few links that you probably have
already seen we have a website called
edu T bio info which is an educational
website where you can gain access to a
lot of free materials free courses to
get training and to learn about some of
the background information and the
terminology that we'll be referring to
so I encourage everybody to join and
create an account show you basically
once you create an account you can go to
your profile and under the profile
you'll be able to see your progress so
the main point of this profile is to
assemble the information about you and
that information will follow along with
the different activities that you
perform for example if you finish or
register for courses if you complete
quizzes
if you do the practical assignments all
of that information will be available
right there under your profile and
you'll be able to see where you are when
you enrolled in different courses and
where you are today the goal of this
profile is to eventually help you
understand your journey and share your
journey with others that are doing
similar things so if you're looking to
advance in your career if you're looking
to get certifications you get
certificates for these courses that
certify your participation and mention
what topics were covered you will also
be able to see how you perform compared
to other people and an important aspect
of this and is that the participants of
this program those that have registered
are going to all be listed under the
organization that we have for this topic
and so let me quickly show you so this
is the page for the organization and the
the page kind of assembles all of the
information that you will need to
benefit from the program so what are
some of those things you will see that
we have the kind of upcoming events so
once you register and become a part of
this program or if you want to register
for events individually you can scroll
through you can see our schedule for
upcoming events and what each event will
be covering and the date you will also
see some of the activity of participants
here underneath you will also see here
are a couple of courses that you would
benefit from taking if you are new to
metagenomics we have right now
introduction to metagenomics and
metagenomics one and in the process of
this program
we'll be also adding the genomics too so
the goal of these courses is to
supplement some of the materials that
we'll be covering in these online
meetings online sessions and you can
really benefit from going through those
and seeing some of the examples that
we'll be discussing you can also see
here under curriculum how these
different courses and events fit
together for the full curriculum of the
programs all you need to do is go there
now what we are trying to do is get
together a group of people that are
together studying a variety of different
topics in metagenomics and can learn by
practically applying the learn skills to
data sets and these data sets are going
to come from public domain from
publications so we will show you walk
you through how to also identify new
data sets that you can analyze using
various methods that we will be
discussing in parallel to this
educational portal you will also get
access to the T bio info platform the T
bio platform was designed by the Taliban
informatics Research Center and a
version of this platform is designed
specifically for education to go along
with some of the course material that
you will find here so what you will find
on this platform are publicly available
algorithms that are packaged inside a
visually intuitive interface so this an
interface really is a pipeline builder
and a version of pipeline execution
script that essentially allows you to
run one script take the results from
that script and pass it on to the next
script after that and we'll learn a
little bit about some of these sections
in particular we'll be looking at a
couple
of examples here under metagenomics
microbiome and amplicon 16s and 18s
sequencing analysis so what we'll be
doing is we will be covering some of
these sections but by participating on
the platform on the educational site
what you can do is you can go right here
under access and fill out your details
specifying here
what is your intended use so for example
if you're interested to use the platform
for education you can say I am a
participant on the educational website
and I would like to apply the learn
skills to a dataset so I would like to
use it for education if you're
interested in using this platform for
research you can also request such
access which is a different type of a
license that you get if you're not sure
and you're just exploring you can also
request a demo account just to see how
it works and once you get a demo account
what you'll be able to do is you'll be
able to use some of these examples that
are pre-loaded on the platform play
around and understand how this pipeline
works so it's a little bit about the
program I also wanted to make sure that
everybody understands that the program
itself is going to last for for a couple
of months November in December and
during those months what we intend to
cover are a variety of topics related to
metagenomics so we will discuss very
early kind of concepts like what is the
microbiome and why do we use sequencing
to study the microbiome what is
next-generation sequencing and how does
it apply to metagenomics data and we'll
talk about that today but we'll also
move on forward from there
and start talking about some of the
analysis methods so how do we analyze
different types of next-generation
sequencing data
that type of analysis could be applied
to different types of applications
detection of some microbes in samples by
separating the host and the pathogen and
then looking in a variety of databases
to spot which pathogens are present
we'll look at metagenomics in the
context of trying to a priori look for
whatever is in the sample without
knowing what exactly we are looking for
so not looking for some specific
pathogen or some specific bacteria but
looking what is in the sample and trying
to analyze the sample from that
standpoint and also we'll look at how we
can study the the taxonomy the
proportions of different types of
organisms composition of the microbiome
and be able to compare different samples
how do we understand the composition
changes from condition to condition
we'll also try to understand interpret
what might that type of analysis reveal
to us and a look at it from several
standpoints we'll look at it from the
standpoint of microbial drug resistance
we look at it from the standpoint of
viral evolution and how virus was
evolved to overcome a series of
challenges that they account or due to
the immune response and we will also
take a look at other types of projects
like the rise of bacteria in soil to
really see their diverse application of
metagenomics that are applicable to this
type of analysis and we hope that all of
you will benefit from joining or this
kind of a journey exploring together
with us and having a discussion so one
of our main objectives is to really
facilitate a discussion about how might
you be interested to apply such
techniques to a topic that is
interesting to you so we encourage all
of you to start thinking about some of
these ideas
if you struggle with any of the
terminology and the topics that we're
covering we are encouraging everybody to
take some of these free online courses
and review the material that we have
there and the sessions will build on
that material hopefully allowing
everybody to get direct hands-on
practical experience on analyzing some
of these types of metagenomic data so
how did we get there how did we get here
and by the way I'm going to be leading
this session but I will be the the whole
program will involve
other speakers as well and we will also
allow for some Q&A sessions where you
can ask questions so if you have any
questions please make sure that you put
those questions in the chat box and I'll
be happy to address those so in today's
lecture we want to talk about how did we
get here what is some background
information why are we even turning to
sequencing to study metagenomics and
then we'll talk about some of the
sequencing techniques though that allow
us to and what do they allow us to study
essentially what kind of data can we
generate so when talking about how do we
get here we're really talking about the
history of metagenomics now a
metagenomics sometimes is confused with
16s sequencing but in reality
metagenomics is a field of study the
field of study of the microbial
community using genomic information so
when we speak about metagenomics we're
really talking about historically when
the microscope was invented it was
invented to spot some of the smaller
things the the microorganisms and the
cells in in bigger organisms and as that
technology started to evolve we started
discovering that there is a whole world
of microbes there's a whole world
of tiny little things that live and work
together as communities and so one of
the first things that happen right after
that is that we discovered that these
microbial communities could be grown and
so here you see a culture of bacteria in
EM Pradesh and you also see different
examples of microorganisms that could be
seen in a microscope so what what we can
do one one of the things that could be
done right is we could extract a
specific strain of a bacteria grow it in
a lab and then we can look at how does
that bacteria grow in different
environments and how does it interact
with a variety of different influences
right if we change its environment so
those types of studies are very limited
because of course to do that we have to
extract the bacteria from its natural
environment from where it is naturally
place it in an artificial environment
and then perform all kinds of tests not
only that it is also believed that only
one to two percent of all bacteria could
actually be cultured in a lab so in if
we want to study how the bacteria grows
how it works how it communicates with
other bacteria in the microbiome we
really have to have an alternative
method of study and so as a result of
that this explosion of sequencing or
high-throughput sequencing technologies
and and by explosion I mean the amount
of sequencing data that is being
produced due to the lowering costs due
to the accessibility of this technology
now we have this whole field of study
called meta genomics and so for any one
of you that is interested in
metagenomics and kind of how did we get
here what are some of the opportunities
and challenges of metagenomics we
a short crash course called introduction
to metagenomics so you can go to the
website and once you are registered you
can go to a collection dedicated to
metagenomics where we have introduction
to metagenomics and metagenomics one and
two of these courses are a very good
start for anyone who is just new to this
whole area and wants to understand a
little bit of where we are in the field
of metagenomics and learn also about
some of the ways that data is being
collected and analyzed in metagenomic
studies so in metagenomics one for
example there are already some examples
and in detail a review of different
sequencing techniques
how does sequencing work what are some
example projects where to find this kind
of data etc so for anyone that is really
starting I highly recommend to take some
of these quizzes and test how you
understand the materials based on some
of the quizzes that are offered
throughout the course so I really
encourage all of you to go through that
material and that will also clarify any
kind of questions that you might have in
terms of the terminology that we use
because a lot of times what will happen
and I'll just give here a quick example
is you will actually be able to hover
over some of the terms that are
mentioned that maybe are not very clear
maybe we don't spend enough time to
explain those terms but you will be able
to hover over those and really look at
what they mean get a definition so I
really encourage all of you to go
through that read through hover over
some of these highlighted words and
understand what they need so what we'll
be doing today is we'll be actually
going through some of the material that
is already covered in these courses as
well but talking a little bit more in
detail about 16s metagenomic sequencing
in the context of next-generation
sequence
in general and how it applies to the
microbial study to the metagenomic
studies so if anyone has any questions
again this would be a good time to ask
those questions during this session and
by questions I mean anything that is not
clear from the material that we're going
through anything that is not clear to
you about the program itself or anything
that's not clear to you from the types
of projects that we are discussing so
really if you have any of those
questions or concerns please feel free
to add them in chat and we'll be happy
to answer them so this session is really
going to be dedicated to 16s metagenomic
sequencing but before that I want to
start with a little bit more background
about sequencing itself so what's unique
about minute genomics is that as all the
other onyx they are really focused on a
single organism right so if you think of
genomics proteomics transcriptomics they
all focus on the whole of a single
organism or today you also have single
cell sequencing technologies you can
look at different types of cells through
cell sorting or you can look at
different tissues or you can look at
different even individual cells right
but still we are going to be looking at
a single organism but in isms especially
microorganisms live in closely related
and tight-knit communities and interact
and in fact their function oftentimes
complements and they complements each
other and also the host that they live
in and so when we want to study such a
community we need to look and study and
understand the genomes of individual
representatives of that community so
metagenomics is the study of the
metagenomes
the genomes of those organisms so we
look at the composition of that
community by looking
at the genetic material that is directly
taken from the environment so this is
something that allows us to bypass this
need to take a single representative and
culture bad bacteria in a lab and it
allows us to to maintain kind of the
natural environment but also the
composition because it's important the
proportions of different types of
bacteria together and also different
types of different types of interactions
so we can really look at that community
from a number of different ways so
that's not to say that we don't apply
sequencing to cultured bacteria so if
you look at and then here we'll start
talking about some of the challenges as
well as we kind of look at me for this
here you see the gut and you want to for
example study the bacteria and the MA
and the microorganisms that live in the
mucus around the gut cells so to do that
obviously there are going to be several
challenges how do we separate what is in
the mucus from all the other cells you
have the immune cells you have the gut
cells you have what's inside the gut so
there's a lot of things that you are
actually sampling and there are two ways
that you can do it you can extract the
mucus and you can culture an individual
strain of bacteria and grow it in a
petri dish in a lab and then sequence
and understand what's going on or you
can take just the full sample and then
culture free sequence that material
selecting now you want to select for
something very specific so we'll talk
about how do we do that before I move on
some non deep is asking questions so
thank you for Bridget for answering that
question so
we see here is really what are some of
the results that we can obtain right and
these are the two types of things that
we might be interested when we are
looking at metagenomics studies we can
look at classification right so
composition of different representatives
inside this community inside the sample
that we have or we might be interested
in looking at complete genomes what
types of genomes so the full sequence of
that genome is important but to do
taxonomic classification the full
sequence of each individual is actually
not that important right and we'll talk
about how to actually do that now in
terms of sequencing the way to prepare
that data right when we take that data
out we then have to produce digital
information about the sample that we
have and that digital information since
we're looking at the genetic material we
need the sequences of DNA or RNA that is
present in the sample that we have so
here are some examples of machines that
produce this kind of sequencing
information men ion is a handheld device
where you can put a sample and it will
produce the sequence you have Illumina
that allows you to fill a whole number
of slots with material and sequence it
and then also PacBio
another example and so all three of
these examples are used for metagenomic
studies there are differences however
you have long reads and short reads and
we'll talk a little bit more about what
that means but essentially we're talking
about some benefits and some downsides
to both types of technologies both min
ion and pag bio produce long reads
however the quality of those long reads
is going to be lower so the reliability
of each individual nucleotide is going
to be lower because
we gained in length however if we are
looking to assemble full genomes the
longer the read of course that's going
to be easier to assemble we have less
pieces to assemble together they are
longer so we can more easily combine
them together Illumina however provides
higher coverage and therefore we have
higher confidence in the sequence of
individual or reads and it's a much more
established technology from the
standpoint of reliability and
availability and it's not as costly so
in fact from the cost perspective
meaning ion would be the cheapest
Illumina is fairly affordable and very
widely used because of that
affordability and PacBio tends to be
more higher-quality
so more reliability than men ion however
it is typically more expensive now
another benefit of some of these newer
technologies like the men ion is the
time that it takes to produce a result
and so here's an example of a
publication that compares how a protocol
using min ion offered an appointment ion
compares to the mysic Illumina
sequencing from the standpoint of time
and from the standpoint of steps that
you need to take to get to a final
result and now when you think about this
and dubinina will have a chance to talk
about PacBio a little bit more but right
now what we want to get to is the 16s
ribosomal RNA sequencing so that's what
this session will be about but I'm happy
to share more material material is about
PacBio as well so when we compare long
read sequencing on something like min
ion which is handheld device so you can
really take it anywhere and also it is
cheap one of the major benefits is the
time that it takes to identify
what is in my sample so if we think
about rapid detection of viruses or
pathogens or a characterization of what
causes a specific effect this is a very
useful method you can see here that
essentially in a couple of steps and in
less than six hours you can get a
detection right typically what we mean
by detection is presence or absence of
specific types of pathogens in Illumina
you you're talking about several
different steps and over 20 hours that
are needed to get to a final result
right so that could play a big role in
your selection of technologies but
understand how these technologies work
and knowing this example of sampling
from the natural environment
let us talk a little bit more about how
16s ribosomal RNA sequencing works and
thank you super genes for putting that
link in there so anyone that's
interested in specifically about PacBio
they have some details available on
their website and if that is a topic
that's interesting to more than a few of
you were happy to schedule a session
maybe discuss in that technology as well
so 16s ribosomal RNA sequencing 16s
ribosomal sequencing is also called
amplicon sequencing it is amplicon
sequencing because it amplifies a region
of ribosomal RNA and so when we talk
about luminous sequencing we're really
talking about several different options
that are available and there we are
looking at the differences from why we
are doing the sequencing in other words
what is the objective of our study in
terms of costs how affordable so maybe
that means how many samples we can
sequence and also talks about
Oh detailed do we need to get our result
so how much detail are we looking for
16s ribosomal RNA is one of the lower
cost and it is also typically used to
understand a taxonomic classification
and composition of a microbiome full
length sequencing 16s ribosomal RNA full
and sequencing meaning we are sequencing
the full 16s ribosomal RNA when we talk
about amplicon sequencing we're talking
about amplified regions of that sequence
and 16s ribosomal RNA shotgun sequencing
typically requires higher sequencing
depth and the goal from the full
metagenomic shotgun sequencing is also
something that is possible with Illumina
sequencing and typically those would be
used for assembling so full metagenomic
shot and sequencing would be used to
assemble full genomes present in a
sample which is of course much more
challenging than trying to look for this
16s region now what is the 16s region
16s region is the ribosomal RNA and this
is characterized we'll talk into the
next slide this is only specific to to
prokaryotes so they're not going to be
included in the host right if we talk
about a sample coming from a human or a
mammalian host we're gonna be taking a
sample and this is an easy way to
separate that prokaryotes in the sample
from any other type of material genetic
material that we have so in a way it is
really a useful way to separate and
separately look at just the prokaryotic
so only the microbial representatives
individuals in the sample but not only
that we also have prime
that could help us detect just the 16s
sample and so you can see right here
this is that 1500 base segment that
could be amplified with PCR but also we
can actually look for some specific
regions and only look at that region and
that will help detect the taxonomy of
our sample in general so we'll talk
about that in detail here in a second
what is ribosomal RNA so the ribosome of
course the ribosome of course is protein
and and that functions to or yes a
complex that produces proteins so it
goes to the RNA mRNA and we can we know
that the prokaryotic ribosome contains
two portions the large subunit and the
small subunit and so what encodes for
the small subunit is actually the 16s
ribosomal RNA and so within this RNA
this is what it looks like
we have multiple what is called hyper
variable regions and these hyper
variable regions are actually what we
can use to detect a specific level
taxonomy so if we talk about how we can
use this material we typically select
for 16s ribosomal RNA and then look for
the specific V 1 to V 9 conserved
regions which are between 30 and 100
base pairs long long and then just those
regions right so sometimes several of
those regions are assembled together in
a single Illumina run and so
you can see how you have a sample
collection and then RNA is isolated or
DNA could be isolated but in our case
we're talking RNAs isolation and then
you have the 16s ribosomal RNA gene that
is amplified for example for the v4
hyper variable region and then once we
have that raw material we sequence that
material that then produces a specific
type of data now another thing so I see
here some discussions about primers and
so all of that falls under the category
of library preparation so all of this
discussion up until now is really about
sample extraction and library
preparation just just to give you a
little more detail about that some of
the kits that are typically used our
mobile DNA extraction kit Teijin DNA
microbiome kit and there is a number of
other kits that are typically designed
extract this type of material from your
raw material and also for library
preparation this is actually going to be
important because one of the biggest
considerations for library preparation
of environmental samples for shotgun
metagenomic sequencing like we talked in
the previous slide it has to do with
this amplification what do we implement
I puff samples like water or swabs they
only yield small amounts of DNA and so
we have to amplify the material that we
have during library preparation an
amplification by PCR can actually over
amplify some of the material that we
have right without our control and that
typically yield a distorted view of the
taxonomy that that we're looking for and
so we often needs to kind of make these
decisions when we have low inputs of DNA
to minimize variability and so you know
we typically want to use amplification
free library preparation methods if we
have low yield of material in our sample
and there are several kids also
available for this including the bio
scientific next flex PCR free DNA
sequencing kit Illumina true seek PCR
free library preparation kit and keep a
hyper prep kit so there's a number of
kits that are specifically designed for
this now whenever the sequencing itself
happens whenever we talk about Illumina
shotgun sequencing of 16s ribosomal RNA
we would typically use paired-end reads
and and reads as you can see right here
this is on the flow cell they're really
sequences of the same element of RNA
shattered RNA that are read from both
sides from the 5 Prime and the three
prime ends and when they are combined
that gives us approximately 250 to 300
base pair long segments and so these are
longer sequence longer reads and we have
multiple representatives of the same
region because we have high coverage and
because of that high coverage we need to
merge them together by looking at just
the ones that actually have pairs so
they have both the forward strand and
the reverse strand reads so we need to
eliminate those that do not have those
pairs and then develop a consensus so
where do the the sequences agree in
order to organize them into these
organizational taxonomic units so to
understand what that means let's talk a
little bit more about what is taxonomy
so taxonomy refers to
the classes of different organisms that
are present in our samples so for
example when we talk about
microorganisms we're talking about a
diverse a diverse population so to say
but the lower the level the more
diversity we will discover right so one
of the useful things for us to think
about when we do this kind of sequencing
when we do this kind of analysis we
really want to look at how much
diversity do we need to be able to
answer a specific question okay so a
question really quickly what is
paired-end reads so as you see right
here individual reads reads our segments
short segments of sequences so when we
say shotgun sequencing shotgun
sequencing refers to shattering the RNA
that we have typically then that
shattered those pieces are going to be
sequenced and so we have this digital
information about each week and so we
can just take them all from one
direction or we can take each one of
those short segments and sequence them
from both directions and when we
sequence them from both directions and
align them together we have a higher
more reliable sequence that we can use
in our downstream analysis so that is
referred to pair 2n degrees and we
typically use paired end read sequencing
when we use these kinds of 16s
metagenomic studies um so a question
here on how to optimize the
amplification of the 16s gene prior to
next generation sequencing the bacterial
16s gene contains nine hypervariable
regions they are
range between 330 and 100 base pairs
long and they're all involved in the
secondary structure of the small
ribosomal subunit and they all have a
degree of conservation that varies
between these hypermile regions and so
the entire 16s sequence allows us to
compare all the hypervariable regions
and so if we take the whole sequence
it's about 1500 base pairs long but
sometimes that's too long
for studies that want to just look at
bacterial community composition and so
when we talk about the Illumina platform
the reads are much more cheap to produce
but they're not that long and so that's
why you know we have up to 300 base
pairs typically in a read and so that's
why you want to sequence the fool the
hyper variable region right so those
regions again range from 30 to 100 base
pairs so you kind of have these
different options right
maiya I think I'm kind of thinking a
long route and answering directly your
question right so one is we can just
amplify the 16s full gene right so if we
go back right here we can actually use
PCR amplification to just focus on 16s
gene or we can actually look at the
specific hypervariable regions right and
again we will use PCR amplification with
specific libraries for those
hypervariable regions so we can look at
all of the hypervariable regions which
is all nine of them or we can look at
one of them or a couple of them and so
they all have you know different degrees
of conservation and so more conserved
regions correlate to higher
taxonomy and let's consider regions to
lower levels such as genus and species
so again it's important to look at this
how do we want to study how much detail
do we want in our resulting data to be
able to answer some of these questions
okay send more questions in this line I
can see at the third step but is written
in PCR amplification of v4 region what
is the significance of v4 over others so
the v4 region is actually one of the
more conserved ones so we can use that
region to place our characterization of
the sample composition within a certain
level of taxonomy
v34 region I have the Illumina protocol
but it does not work for all types of
samples especially with low amount
biological fluid especially so with as I
mentioned there are some specific types
of samples that we're talking about you
know if they're from water or from swabs
so you don't have a lot of RNA
sufficient RNA or DNA to capture you
know what's happening right so if you
have again we can go back to the slide
right here right when we have a swab
we're really talking about taking the
mucus and then we have a limited number
of that material to be able to extract
what we're looking for so we can
actually you know think of the PCR route
when we amplify the material but that
amplification unfortunately is not going
to uniformly amplify all of the present
data all of the presence RNA so if we
use a non PCR amplification library prep
it's not going to have sufficient
material sometimes to study everything
that we might want to study
so that's briefly to answer your
question any other questions about any
of this
his duplication and triplication may
create air during process and
specifically during data analysis
exactly yeah so that is one of the
things that we'll start talking about
next time and we'll talk about how do we
apply this technique right so now you
understand that when we talk about
metagenomic sequencing we're actually
talking about many different types of
sequencing we're talking about many
different types of instruments so at
least several types of instruments when
we talk about you know different
strategies to produce our data we need
to make a decision on which instrument
is going to be used we're going to be
looking at which you know read length
and then asking June 50 to base base
pair is think of a read gonna be look
for in strategy of collect the
instrument that we choose library
preparation read lengths and then that
will define what kind of analysis we are
going to be trying to perform and it
will also be defining how can we utilize
that analysis result what kind of
information can we get out of that
result so as an example let's take a
look here
what we are looking at is biological
classification which is taxonomy of
these microorganisms what kind of
taxonomy can we use to characterize a
community right now what it is a
community a community is going to be a
microbiome so what we expect to find in
one of these areas on the human body for
example or this could be in the
environment from the soil from the water
etc so when we look at those we are
looking to study diversity sometimes
sometimes we just want to look at
diversity and that would be an example
of using 16s
amplicon ribosomal RNA because we're
going to be looking at amplify v4 for
example regions or before in v3 regions
that will help us find just here the
this type of what's called alpha and
beta diversity so how much based our
species for example we have and then we
can compare them and understand the
differences however sometimes you want
to look at for example presence of a
specific detection of a specific
organism for example a virus I want to
know whether there is a specific virus
and how much of it and what is the
diversity of that specific virus so if
that is my question then I cannot use
16s sequencing for that because I am
going to be more interested in the full
genomes of that virus and I want to
study in detail the differences between
those genomes between the sequences of
those genomes and a virus is of course
going to be may be several thousand base
pairs long
you know maybe fifteen or thirty or
forty thousand but we will also look at
the sequence itself and not how diverse
a sample is so very different strategies
are designed around the analysis needs
and are designed around the application
the use of that analysis okay so another
question I mean how to optimize the
amplification protocol regarding the
number of amplification cycles and input
DNA so may what may be a good discussion
for us to have is to better understand
exactly what is it that you are trying
to sequence and what is your objective
so what I propose is for you to maybe if
you are interested in analyzing this
kind of data first of all you guess you
can write your question directly or you
can also
go as I showed right here where you
request access and you can write your
type of a project that you are
interested in and we will be happy to
address any of your questions maybe more
than one on one type of a discussion if
that makes sense so again the the
shotgun sequencing is unique in the
sense that we're trying to sequence a
large in diverse pool of microbes each
one of them has different size and a lot
of times they're mixed with host DNA
right so when we talk about 16s
sequencing we are really talking about
being able to separate 16s ribosomal RNA
which is only going to be for
prokaryotes and we then look for a
specific region so we look typically in
the hypervariable regions and then we
have high coverage if we use aluminum we
have high coverage for those specific
hypervariable regions and we are able to
look at the taxonomy of our sample I
mean how to optimize the amplification
protocol regarding the number of
amplification cycles in for dinner yeah
sorry yeah so I hope that the tenets now
when we look at the analysis after that
right what we wanted to talk about today
was that okay we understand what we are
sequencing we're taking the encoding
region for this small unit of the
ribosome and we are taking these these
specific hypervariable regions
that are going to be involved in the
secondary structure of the small
ribosomal unit so because the ribosome
has to be as stable these regions are
conserved and they are conserved so that
we and we can use that conservation so
that we can study tectonic conversion
into reads can on different in
duplicates or triplicates and if it
differs then there might be air is it
correct so you're talking about pair and
rereads as i understand right so pair
and reads yeah if you have you know two
of the example of the same thing and you
can see a change in just of one of the
copies that you have right so you have
two copies if you have a change in just
one copy then you know it might be a
mistake but if you have a change in two
copies that is your higher confidence
that you are finding a real change right
I'm talking about in the context of now
aligning those reads to the reference
genome right so whenever we will talk
more about so after this you know and
maybe this is a good transition to this
final slide we will talk about better
under naming the microbiome so we'll
actually look at some examples where in
the context of those examples for
example when we look at gut health and
the brain or the gut microbiota right
when we look at this example of what we
saw here right these different types of
micro biomes we'll talk about how these
different considerations is about what
are we think when saying how are we
sequencing and then ultimately that will
dictate how we are going to be able to
analyze the data that we have so we will
talk about in the context of very
specific projects thinking about the
objectives that we have in each project
will be able to see how we can leverage
this type of it's
Niek of 16s hyper variable meaning
amplicon sequencing how we can leverage
it in these specific types of projects
so again what I wanted to encourage
everyone to do is and I'll talk a little
bit more in detail what we're going to
be doing next but I want to kind of
summarize what we covered today we
covered today how we can in the context
of this program any one of you can get
access to free materials if you have
some of these questions in other words
how is the sequencing done how how do we
take samples prepare those samples for
sequencing what is the process of
sequencing and what we recommend are
these two courses that we prepared
specifically for that in introduction to
metagenomics and metagenomics one so if
we just take a look at introduction to
metagenomic some of the material that we
covered today will talk about some of
these strategies so you would be able to
learn about the different types of
metagenomic sequencing 16s amplicon kind
of if you don't understand some of the
terminology again you can hover over and
learn about different types of
sequencing and then also if you take the
metagenomics one course and the
metagenomics one course will also cover
some of that information so you know
more for logical steps of different
types of metagenomic sequencing and
things like that including some example
data set so you can actually look at
some examples of where 16s ribosomal RNA
is used and some places where the full
assembled metagenomic sequence is
important to analyze the data okay and
also some of these materials will talk
about the biological background and
methods something that we also covered
briefly today
okay so here you can learn about the 16s
ribosomal RNA some of the extraction
techniques for either 16s or whole
metagenomic sequencing you can read
about the reads and and what is that and
you can also see some of these terms
that you know might not be very clear
and really learn about different types
of metagenomic studies for example what
we won't talk about in detail in this
program are Meir transcriptomics
biochemistry and other other types of
important aspects of microbial genomics
and microbial studies ok so again what
we will talk about in our next session
in our next session we'll be talking
about how of 16s amplicon sequencing is
useful to study the microbial
communities and their impact
specifically on human health so we'll
talk about examples with the gut brain
axis where we'll look at changes in
composition between different types of
diets and also the impact on behavior
and we'll also start talking about an
example where we can look at how diverse
micro gut microbe ah
you
this will give us insight into how we
can leverage some of these techniques to
analyze different type of data and study
the microbiome but also just to use
microbiome as a mean
you
fools that will be important in the
future aspects of our discussion so next
session will be focused on the
microbiome we will then talk about the
analysis some of the challenges with the
analysis the challenges of short reads
and what we discussed today with the
paired end reads and the hypervariable
regions and all those things
what are organizational and taxonomic
units and and how we actually make sure
that they are accurately represented in
the analysis we will have then another
session to map the data that we are into
databases and what's going to be
important for us is to try to understand
the presence of a variety of different
microbes or microbial species by looking
at databases with annotated hyper
variable region sequences so actual full
sequences of these hyper variable
hypervariable regions in different
databases like silva Greenjeans ncbi etc
and then after we talk about mapping on
databases and seeing some of those
examples we'll kind of review the full
pipeline how does a fool
16's metagenomic sequence type line book
what do we implement what are the
different steps what is the significance
of different steps and one is going to
be the output and what can we do with
that outlet right the output could be
modified based on our needs then after
that we'll review some other examples
where we can use full metagenomic
sequences of the specific type of a
bacteria so for example we'll look at
microbial response to soil composition
because when we look at just one example
right right a bacteria would be an
example of when you take a look at just
a single type of a bacterial riser
bacteria that's it and you look at that
riser bacteria in terms of the changes
in its genomes
so you have these mutations you have
these changes in the genome and the
question is how do we associate those
changes with environmental changes for
example presence or absence some
specific chemicals in the soil will then
talk about other examples of
metagenomics so a study of another type
of a problem statement where we're
trying to detect viral genome presence
right so if you take a sample from the
human blood for example or if you take a
sample from a culture where you're
trying to produce biologics for example
vaccine production how do you analyze
that data to only focus on non host
non-human RNA or DNA and then find maybe
traces of some specific viral or
bacterial genomes and then to try to
understand what does that mean does it
mean that we have the full genome does
it mean that we just have some small
segments that resemble some genome but
they're not really a genome so we'll
talk about some of that so we're really
gonna be talking about some examples of
uses of metagenomics and projects where
they could be used we'll talk about
phylogeny how can we understand the
phylogeny or the relationship
evolutionary relationship divergence
based on for example specific genes or
specific regions and we'll talk about
full of genetic analysis in the context
of metagenomics and we'll talk about
drug resistance drug resistance is a big
problem in tuberculosis we're actually
prevention now is one of the main
focuses because we have this problem
with drug resistance drug-resistant
strains of tuberculosis and so we'll
look at an example study with new data
that is being collected recently
and we'll look at how to analyze that
data and what types of analysis methods
can help us spot and characterize this
drug resistance so understand it also on
the biological level so these are some
of exciting projects that we'll be
covering in the whole program again for
anyone that wants to register and
participate in the full program if
you're not sure you can go ahead and
start with the free courses that are
available for anybody all you need to do
is register for free and take some of
the online courses if you want to
participate in events like the one that
we had today
work with others on your own projects
develop your own project and
metagenomics and see it from beginning
to conclusion and if you want to have a
certificate for the program itself
covering all of these different variety
of topics we welcome all of you to go to
this link finalize your registration and
as a result you'll be getting access to
the program to the sessions we have and
also we will guide you to utilize the
platform and analyze data so I'm really
excited about this program we'll start
meeting again next week we have a number
of sessions coming up that are going to
be very exciting and I will after this
session is over we will be emailing you
the recording of this session so you can
review some of the materials that we
covered and we'll also share with you
the presentation that we have today and
then starting from next week we'll
really focus on those of you that have
completed the registration sending you
account information for all of you and
we'll start sharing more data sets that
we can start practice with together so
any final questions you're welcome to
put them in chat I'll be happy to answer
them you are also welcome to directly
contact us through the form that we have
on the site or we have several of our
members here in the session you can
email us directly
okay so if there are no more questions
then it was really good to see all of
you here today and we are going to meet
again next week for those of you that
would like to continue joining these
sessions and if you have any questions
Thank You beep ship for putting your
email address there you're welcome to
email us a question do I have to pay to
attend all the sessions as I have
already registered if you already
registered then you don't have to pay
beep so if you could maybe check Agni
and the registration there will be happy
to you know if you have the membership
for the program you do not have to
register for individual events unless
you want to I mean you can just click
right here and register all events and
if you already have the membership then
you'll be just automatically included in
all of the events and we'll be sending
you the login information for each one
of our events if you want to just join
one of the events and you don't want the
full membership you can find the event
that you're interested in and then
register now right here so if I click
right here
each event has a specific for those that
are registered it's free for those that
are not registered you will have to pay
for that individual event and then we
can send you out the information we
actually have a list of those that have
completed the registration you're
welcome to connect with be sure to ask
any of those types of questions about
registration how do I put my target and
current project and inquiries on the
website well first of all you can email
us directly but if you would like to
submit a project an easy way to do that
like I said is you have this access link
right here so if you go to this link
this is the link where we have our am
political platform the analytic once you
get to that link you'll see something
like this and right here on the top menu
you have access so this is designed for
those of you that would like to analyze
data even if it's your own data if it's
data that you're planning to generally
and you want some assistance with that
data but you wouldn't have to do is you
would have to just fill out this form
what is your your name your state region
free city a company or organization and
then right here a topic of interest or
intended use you actually type in you
know I am working on a metagenomics
project and would like to analyze data I
would look to speak with someone right
about the analysis and data preparation
something like that right and then
include your phone number so we know
well how to reach you and then you
submit and we get that email we'll
review these daily and then we can get
back to you and schedule a time to speak
one-on-one and discuss in detail how you
planning to generate your data what are
some of the analysis techniques that
might be applicable if you need help
with analysis we can also help you but
also then talk about interpretation and
I think learning about the context of
metagenomics in a program like this is
obviously a great place to start
okay well if there are no other
questions again I think we covered a lot
today
so thank you again for joining and we'll
be seeing you again